en estas imágenes le vemos persiguiendo
a una persona en un parque de la ciudad
francesa de ansi armado con un cuchillo
el hombre atacó a seis personas entre
ellas cuatro niños de entre 22 meses y
tres años las víctimas fueron
trasladadas al hospital toda la clase
política francesa reaccionó de inmediato
el presidente Manuel mccom denunció la
agresión como un acto de cobardía
atentado absolutamente cobarde esta
mañana en un parque de ansi niños y un
adulto entre la vida y la muerte la
nación está conmocionada nuestros
pensamientos están con ellos sus
familias y los servicios de emergencia
la primera ministra Elizabeth fue al
lugar de la tragedia estamos
conmocionados por este acto atroz de
indescriptible cuando afecta a los niños
creo que todos estamos profundamente
consternados Y hoy todo nuestro país
está en estado de shock según la
identidad declarada por el atacante
nació en Siria en 1991 y obtuvo el
estatuto de refugiado en 2023 mientras
se lleva a cabo la investigación las
autoridades descartan el carácter
terrorista del atentado el móvil está
aún por determinar a partir de los
primeros elementos de la investigación y
lo digo con la mayor reserva ya que se
trata de hechos ocurridos hace apenas
cuatro horas No hay motivo terrorista
aparente mientras el incidente ha
causado una gran conmoción en todo el
país en París diputados y miembros del
gobierno guardaron Un minuto de silencio
en la asamblea nacional